hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts pth testing and patients with
chronic disease kidney disease
I'm Robert Castellanos of lab rooms and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Dyess oren dice
oren incorporated offers the broadest
fully automated infectious disease and
specialty Diagnostics menu including the
best-in-class vitamin D these quality
assays are analyzed on the versatile
liaison excel platform they provide
value through sales service and support
solutions to clinical laboratories by
consolidating the menu in order to
streamline processes and increase
efficiency for more information please
visit daya Soren comm we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon and the
lower right-hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
educational credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of a
in your credits I would now like to
introduce you to today's speaker dr.
Kevin Martin dr. Kevin Martin is
director of the division of Nephrology
at st. Louis University and professor of
internal medicine he has served as a
chairman of the general medicine B study
section of the National Institute dr.
Martens clinical research interests
include parathyroid hormone vitamin D
metabolism and secondary hyperthyroidism
he has authored 230 publications in two
professional journals including the New
England Journal of Medicine Kinney
international the American Journal of
kissing disease and clinical Journal of
the American Society of Nephrology I
will now turn it over to dr. Martin for
his presentation hello everybody and
thank you for joining this webinar today
I'm going to talk about PTH testing in
patients with chronic kidney disease I'm
going to start by outlining how mineral
metabolism is controlled in normal state
and then tell a little bit about the
disturbances that occur in the paths of
kidney disease and emphasized the
importance of PTH and to then talk in
detail about how we measure PTH and and
some of the issues involved there that
need to have perhaps to improve so let's
begin with a quick overview of normal
physiology where a complex system is in
place to maintain the concentrations of
calcium and blood in the normal and type
normal range this system although it
looks complex and perhaps is but it's
very effective and the integrated
actions of all these factors can keep
the
Lavina is calcium within a very narrow
range maybe with a range of less than
10% for an entire lifetime so at the
slide the depicts is in response to a
fall in the levels of ionized calcium
the parathyroid glands are stimulated
and to secrete PTH and then PTH does
several things a tax upon had the bone
to mobilize calcium and phosphorus it
acts upon the kidney to increase the
reabsorption of calcium and also acts
upon the kidney and to increase the
production of 125 diet oxy vitamin D
which is the active form and the - then
where will act upon the intestine where
it will also increase the absorption of
calcium so all of these effects then are
designed to restore a fall in the level
of serum calcium back to normal but
you'll notice that when PTH resorbs
calcium from bone it also brings with it
some phosphorus which is undesirable in
this situation because it would tend to
offset the correction in calcium and at
the same time and when 125 vitamin D
acts upon the intestine it - error
results not only in the absorption of
calcium but also in the absorption of
phosphate again the rise and phosphate
absorption is an undesirable consequence
so these undesirable consequences of
simultaneously mobilizing phosphate are
handled in two ways one of the actions
of PTH upon the kidney is to increase
phosphate excretion and so that would
tend to offset this rise in phosphorus
in blood and in addition there's a
separate hormone fgf 23 which not only
will act have its own actions on the
parathyroid but also is an important
hormone for increasing phosphate
excretion by the kidneys so the
integrated result of all of these
actions is
triggered by a fall in ionized calcium
is that the parathyroid hormone vitamin
D fgf 23 systems all work together to
correct the abnormality and restore the
ionized calcium back to normal and as I
said it works extremely efficient
efficiently and that's because the
effect of calcium and PTH release is
controlled very tightly and here's a
study showing the effect of
extracellular calcium under release of
parathyroid hormone from isolated
parathyroid cells and you can see it's a
very steep curve in the mid portion here
and it's set really in the with its
midpoint about where the level of
extracellular calcium concentrations
need to be in blood so this is important
because it can respond very quickly up
or down in response to various stimuli
and begin an immediate effect to restore
the abnormality is back to normal so
let's move then to talk about what
happens in kidney disease and let me
point out that disturbances in calcium
phosphorus parathyroid hormone and
vitamin D metabolism have been
traditionally recognized and treated for
their role in causing renal bone disease
or by the words renal osteodystrophy so
this has changed a little bit in in
recent years and because it has now
recognized that the consequences of
these abnormalities are mineral
metabolism extend beyond the skeleton
and in fact have been implicated as
important factors in cardiovascular
disease and contribute importantly to
mortality in these patients with chronic
kidney disease so actually what happens
now is the new term was introduced CKD
MBD standing for chronic kidney disease
mineral and bone disorder but what it
actually is as as a combination of
abnormalities not only here in in bone
but also as giving rise to a number of
biochemical abnormalities which we'll
discuss these can contribute to vascular
calcification and which is important
contributor to cardiovascular disease
and mortality and and of course these
are overlap to a greater or lesser
extent and contribute substantially to
morbidity and mortality in patients with
chronic kidney disease making it
important for us to try to detect and to
and then begin treatment for these
issues so in the last several years
conic kidney disease has been divided
into several stages and by changes
really in the in in the level of of GFR
so you can have a normal G F R within
the presence of kidney disease usually
GFR is good but those other
manifestations of this and this is the
early stages where we need to assess for
complications and begin to treat them to
try to minimize any of these other
effects that I've mentioned whether it
be on bone or cardiovascular system or
the mineral abnormalities as kidney
disease get work gets worse than it can
progress through various stages where we
have to begin a clinical attack on
minimizing collateral damage and the
effects on bone and the heart and these
efforts need to intensify as GFR err
falls further so that we can minimize
these abnormalities taking place when
kidney disease progresses to an advanced
stage or maybe even when dialysis is
required to provide some support in the
absence of sufficient kidney function
and to keep the patient alive
so just to illustrate when these
problems occur this is a slide from one
of the recent papers from doctors
isakova and other
and just showing really that PTH levels
begin to rise very early in the corsa
chronic kidney disease and rise well
above the normal range by the time
certainly by the time
kidney disease reaches stage stage 3 now
it's not the only abnormality that it
that occurs earlier M but the the a
number of abnormalities both in calcium
metabolism and vitamin D and phosphorus
as well as intrinsic abnormalities in
the parathyroid glands that that
contribute had to all of these
consequences and the last one on the
side which I won't really address is
there's an abnormal response of the
skeleton to PTH in the presence of
kidney disease meaning that you usually
have to have higher levels of PTH than
normal to try to maintain own turnover
in the normal range so here's an example
of what happens with the levels of
active vitamin D in the course of kidney
disease and you can see on this slide
that the levels of 125 vitamin D begin
to fall here the orange bar when kidney
disease is mild and progressively fall
as kidney disease gets worse going from
left to right on the slide and you can
see also in the blue line that PTH
levels have begin to increase throughout
the course of chronic kidney disease and
Ryan certainly above the normal range by
the the midpoint here and this can vary
substantially by the type of kidney
disease and and a variety of other
factors but nonetheless suffice to say
at this time that that these
abnormalities and bone and mineral
metabolism begin to occur early in the
course of chronic kidney disease and
progressed throughout if treatment is
not undertaken so probably what happens
is as illustrated in this slide where
because of this disturbed bone and
mineral metabolism several of these
hormones
have normal early in the course of
kidney disease and this slide depicts
what might happen not only to PTH shown
here in green but this may be even
preceded by changes in the other hormone
I mentioned that fgf 23 are indeed by a
progressive fall in Pluto which is
intimately involved in fgf 23 metabolism
and all of these clearly start early and
can get progressively worse as kidney
disease progresses so with that brief
background of the abnormalities and the
timing of events I want to turn the
focus to 2 PTH and which is certainly a
major player in mediating all of these
complex interactions and causing the
complications of the skeleton in the
heart in the blood vessels and a variety
of other tissues so here's a diagram of
PTH it's an 84 amino acid peptide and
it's biological actions are to increase
calcium and blood and to decrease
phosphate in blood as I mentioned
earlier when you have a normal kidney
function it's absolutely important in
terms of structure function studies and
to have the first few amino acids in
place here certainly the first two or
three are critically important for any
biologic activity but most of the
biologic activity if not all of the
biologic activity of PTH is contained
within these first perhaps 34 amino
acids of PTH so the n-terminal 1 234 PTH
which can mediate as I said most if not
all of the biological actions of PTH so
the the idea that we're going to discuss
in more detail now is how to measure PTH
in blood and on this slide it shows how
PTH assays have evolved over the years
the first PTH an SI was introduced in
the
sixties using the radio immunoassay
technique by dr. yellow and and you can
see that the first antibodies that were
raised here against PTH were directed
see that if I kept my pointer and again
here were directed towards the
c-terminal region of the PTH molecule
shown by this blue bar here so these
assays were useful and sort of opened
the field to some of the parathyroid
hormone physiology but the assays were
extremely variable and became really
problematic in the in the course of
chronic kidney disease as I'll show you
in a minute and probably a decade later
and another assay was was introduced
with its recognition site somewhere in
the middle of the molecule the so called
mid region molecules that became popular
and this performed a little bit better
clinically but again was subject to a
lot of variability and particularly
problematic in the presence of kidney
disease now as I've mentioned all of the
biologic activity is contained within
the first thirty four amino acids so why
wouldn't it make sense to try to direct
an antibody against this region and
maybe that should perform clinically
better
so such assays we're introduced and
unfortunately really didn't perform
better mostly I think now looking back
just for reasons of sensitivity etc so
the big breakthrough in PTH assay then
came with the first-generation immuno
metric assays using a two antibody
technique where the PTH could be
captured from blood by an antibody
directed towards the c-terminus for
example and then detected with the
second antibody directed towards the
n-terminus so these this technique was
introduced and gave rise to this whole
series of
what were called intact PTH assays that
are currently in widespread use and in
fact if you order PTH from almost any
clinical site these days you will get
one of these various assays which we'll
talk about more in a minute labeled as
intact PTH and and finally refinement
and this was introduced later which we
will also talk about where the detection
antibody was moved right to the very end
terminus of the PTH molecule and so
really should only measure P th one 284
the full-length molecule and perhaps a
way to exclude some PTH fragments that
really heard the root of the problems
with all this P th si
so here's an example of what happens
within the parathyroid cell PTH is made
as a full-length one 284 peptide and
stored in secretory granules pending a
stimulus for secretion if there's a
fallen the levels of ionized calcium and
blood it signals at the calcium sensing
receptor at the parathyroid membrane and
causes the granules to fuse with the
plasma membrane and enter enter blood if
if calcium levels are high rather than
low and then two signaling at the
calcium receptor PTH that's manufactured
in the parathyroid cell can undergo
degradation within the gland and even to
various fragments here perhaps smaller
molecular weight fragments with
truncated and terminus as shown here
have perhaps larger fragments of PTH
really missing the entire amino terminal
of 34 amino acids or so and perhaps even
ever and terminal peptides themselves
and these indeed can be secreted also
and appear in the blood so you can begin
to see a complex picture here of how
many problems by the rise of PTH sa when
trying to pick the one 284 molecule from
the blood because in the circulation
simplified form we really have a family
of P th peptides not only the P th one
284 the full-length peptide but also n
terminally truncated molecules some
larger C terminal fragments some smaller
C terminal fragments and probably very
little if any have a biologically active
n terminal fragment but you can see the
issue here is how do you begin to pick
these the intact peptide or the peptide
of interest out of this complex mixture
of PTH peptides in serum but it becomes
even more complex and I thought it's
nicely illustrated by this old
experiment from dr. Mayer many years ago
where he successfully was able to
cannulate the the venous effluent of
parathyroid glands of live animals and
and when he fractionated this by gel
filtration so separating things by
molecular size he was able to
demonstrate that what came out of the
gland was a mixture of the intact
hormone here at the ro and also smaller
molecular weight PTH fragments and
interesting enough as you can see both
to the left and to the right of this
this varies according to the state of
calcium and blood if serum calcium is
low so hypocalcemia most of what comes
out of the gland is the intact PTH and
whereas if the calcium is high in blood
some PTH still comes out but it's not
the biologically active one-day t4 which
should come here it's a smaller
molecular weight a fragment of PTH that
has no biologic activity so the
important point here is the proportion
of PTH and PTH fragments that come from
the gland can be varied according to the
level of serum calcium and it kind of
makes sense in a way because we've said
that PTH
responsible for the minute-to-minute
control of serum calcium it takes about
20 minutes to manufacture PTH from an
initial signal in the gland so what
actually happens as the PTH is being
made all the time but being degraded
within the gland if it's not required
yeah and so the builds up this pool of
fragments within the parathyroid gland
that I mentioned earlier but if serum
calcium goes low the degradation can
immediately reduced in a very by rare
very rapid acting effect and so making
active PTH rapidly available to correct
the fall in the levels of ionized
calcium so it makes physiologic sense
that you'd have a mechanism for rapid
release of PTH and rapidly rapidly
making PTH available if indeed there's a
stimulus but this calcium effect on the
fragments that I mentioned means of the
ratio between active PTH and PTH
fragments can vary according to the
level of calcium and blood and
complicating the measurement and
interpretation of PTH and just to make
matters infinitely more complicated
these PTH factory fragments can also
appear from metabolism of the active
hormone in peripheral tissues and shown
here you can see that if you inject
purified PTH one 284 into an animal and
then sample what's in blood as time goes
on
and you can see that PTH 1 284 begins to
disappear and fragments begin to appear
so that these fragments can can occur
not only from secretion of the
parathyroid gland but also from
metabolism in peripheral tissues so what
does this mean then in terms of what we
might encounter in clinical medicine so
first let's look at a normal situation
shown in this pie chart here you can see
that here in a normal person
there's the orange slice of pie is the
active PTH there's a small amount of PTH
inactive fragment and so called PTH 784
as I'll show you in a minute there's
actually a family of peptides but the
vast majority of the circulating PTH
peptides are shown by the blue part of
the pie which are inactive smaller
molecular weight PTH fragments in the
setting of chronic kidney disease you
can see those marked increases in the
levels of PTH there's a tremendous
increase in the PTH fragments shown in
blue because they depend on the kidney
and for excretion from the body and this
is approximately equal amounts of intact
PTH and then the slice of the pie in
yellow showing the 784 family of
peptides so in actual fact as I
mentioned that these there's a whole
family of PTH peptides here with varying
truncations from the n-terminus on
making it very complicated to try to
measure PTH unless you have extreme
specificity of your assay and so if you
look at this slide and take the various
commercial assays that are available at
the present time and and look at a
single patient sample you can see the
results that can be obtained here can go
from a value of 54 in in this assay ad
to a value of a hundred and eighty-three
in this assay so from a clinical
perspective then you need to know what's
correct is the PTH 50 or is it a hundred
and eighty and how can it vary so much
across the various PTH assays and it
turns out that the reason for the
there's several reasons for this
discrepancy but a major one is
commercial PTH assays react differently
to this PTH 7 to 84 family of peptides
some recognizing and extremely well
some recognizing that extremely poorly
and so with this kind of variation of
what's being measured in the plasma it's
not surprising that there's tremendous
variation across all of these commercial
assays that are in use so to hammer home
this point a little bit more and this is
a simplified diagram of what can happen
in a patient with advanced kidney
failure and if you measure PTH in one of
these commercial PTH assays and get a
value of 500 this could represent equal
parts for example of intact PTH or the
PTH 784 family which as a reminder does
not have biologic activity or the value
of 500 could represent only 100
picograms of active PTH and 400
picograms of inactive PTH fragments or
it could measure mean that was 400 pika
grams of active PTH and very little 784
family of peptides yet in an intact
assay depending on beyond the particular
assay in use and you would get a value
of 500 and you can see then that this is
really the issue it's a problem a
problem of interpretation it's a problem
of biological correlation and makes the
proper interpretation of assays very
difficult indeed
and there are clinical examples for this
situation absolutely occurs and can be
easily easily demonstrated so for the
even more recent a more comprehensive
data looking at the recognition of PTH
784 family of peptides of various essays
you can see that it varies quite
considerably among all of the commercial
PTH assays and that are available so it
is possible and I alluded to this
briefly it is
possible to exclude all of these 784 and
family of peptides from PTH assays such
as the intact PTH assays that I've been
mentioning so here is one such as our
diagram oven showing what is being
measured by HPLC you can see that in
this sample there's a lot of PTH one to
84 and quite a bit of PT 8 7 to 80 for
family over here but if you move the
detection antibody for PTH to the very
end terminus of the molecule then on
HPLC all that is being measured is a
intact one to 84 peptide so there are
such assays have been generated and are
in clinical use and we talk a little bit
more about those in detail because that
eliminates a lot of the complications
that arise from the non specificity of
the intact PTH assays and the varying
reactivity to all of this 784 family of
peptides so you can see with this being
the case of PTH sa at the moment when
this KD go group met to try to make
clinical practice guidelines you can
already begin to see that the extent of
the difficulties that might be involved
involved here and to try to suggest but
a reasonable levels of PTH to try to
associate with good outcomes in patients
with kidney disease so the really two
steps at this over the past 10 or 15
years and the first one was from a group
goes by the in acronyms of K dokie and
they suggest that a good range for PTH
and dialysis patients there should be
between 150 and 300 to make guidelines
for where you say calcium should be and
you're faster it should be and the and
in general these were accepted and
thought to be reasonable clinical goals
to be exo's associated with good
outcomes so the problem here that that
the assays used
to generate these kind of numbers is no
longer in existence and have given way
to the variety of intact pth essays that
I've mentioned in the past few slides so
later on then
these guidelines were refined by que
digo had a group and they tried to
address this issue of variation in PTH
assay and tried to suggest that this
might be improved then in terms of
targets by using a multiple of the upper
limit of normal and suggested a good PTH
range might be between two times and
nine times the upper limit of normal and
for for all of these aspects that might
exist and in this way tried to achieve
some homogeneity in recommendations for
plasma allowing for the variable results
obtained by the different commercial
assays that are in use and unto a large
part large degree this is at least
partially successful but we still have a
variety of epidemiologic evidence that
tends to keep that the best range here
in this in this range of PTH values so
somewhere in assays that are close to
the original one to do it's still
probably a reasonable range to try to
shoot for but allows values to run a
little bit higher if indeed the assay in
use detects is 784 family a little bit
better but the issue is still
problematic because I'm not going to go
into the details of this here but these
boxes are trying to classify patients
whether you're in range or out of range
according to these que digo practice
guidelines and using different assays
and this kind of numbers you can see
that the results are still quite quite
variable and so here you get a lot of
dots in the white box here here you get
much fewer with this assay and here you
get somewhere in between so it's not
ideal by any me
for trying to achieve homo homogeneity
or validation of these practice
recommendations so to summarize this
part let me just say that the target PT
a transfer dialysis patients recommended
in the original k dokey practice
guidelines at 153 to 300 was based upon
correlations with bone biopsy and
correlated well using this intact PTH
assay but in this essay is not available
any longer so that was meant the need
for and to accommodate a different range
of PTH and and also have it the more
recent data was able to find better
correlations with some cardiovascular
issues and already suggesting that
broadening of the range might be
beneficial and so these were there was
the information that caused the que digo
group to try and change their target
range but the big question remains as
shown here is what about all these PTH
assays and do they really pair correlate
and should the targets be valid and how
could this problem have be solved should
we should we try to standardize PTH
assays and we'll talk a little bit more
about that in a minute should we apply
correction factors to the various essays
that exists of the thicket use targets
appropriate targets or should we just
use targets that are specific and to a
given assay and so that's where they the
que digo group came in the industry
commendation at the bottom here so it
says that they we should try and keep it
with two and nine times the upper limits
are normal for these particular assays
and maybe that would begin had to cause
some coalescence and corrections at the
various PD agent as
be used so there's another problem with
this though is how good is your
reference range if you're multiplying by
an upper limit of normal and so yeah you
should really be sure who your normals
are and and this was approached by
Cavalli and others who really tried to
be sure that the normal values were
indeed normal and take into account the
chemistry's and those that you consider
normal
not just people are convenient in the
lab for example but make sure they
didn't have changes in serum calcium
that the kidney disease was really
normal that they weren't taking
medicines that could interfere with the
control of bone and mineral metabolism
they didn't have kidney stones and most
important that they weren't deficient or
insufficient in terms of vitamin D and
so they took on to try to screen normals
for this and found that that if he were
careful with the normal subjects to set
a normal range that you did indeed find
differences in the values and that could
be significant for example if you look
here in this I say I'm sorry in this as
I appear there the Alexis I say the
upper limit of normal is 65 by the
manufacturer but if you make sure your
normals are indeed normal and then the
upper limit of normal is only 50 so then
it becomes makes a difference if you're
multiplying 50 by 9 or 65 by 9 it has an
upper limit of normal you'll see that
you're going to get there quite a bit of
difference similarly and this has a down
here if you multiply 36 by 9 or 54 by 9
you have a proper you get quite a spread
in the range and again with this as I
hear of 50 are almost 90 so the upper
limit of normal is if it's loosely
defined is not very satisfying
terms of trying to homogenized the PTA
chasse's and the difference that that
that can make here is if we took a value
of any of these ranges here in this
assay it would it would you would have a
range here of say 170 to almost 800 but
if you controlled your normals it's
between say 100 and 400 so you can begin
to get a flavor of the difference this
makes and and how unsatisfactory it is
to specify multiples of the upper limits
of normals
if you don't really rigorously define at
the normal population from which the
normal range was defined so clearly we
have a ways to go in trying to get some
agreement and homogeneity and how to
define these results so one part of the
practice guidelines said when suggested
at least that when you report lab tests
for patients with CKD we we the k dokie
que digo group I'm sorry the the
practice guidelines group recommend that
clinical laboratories actually say which
method is is in use and report any
changes in methods if they changed their
sample source are handling specific
specific specifications so that you can
facilitate the appropriate
interpretation of biological data and so
so this is important and and maybe we'd
like to see in the field as of you at
the lab reports of PTH value to say what
assay is used in our own Hospital for
example the hospital lab changed from
one PTH si to another and didn't inform
the clinicians so all of a sudden we
began seeing values for P th that are
almost twice what we thought they should
be in these patients and then inquiry
then the lab said oh yes we changed our
PTA
get a normal range didn't differ that
much but they didn't rigorously look at
patients with advanced kidney disease
where all of this problem arises because
of the differential detection of these
PTH fragments so it would be really nice
if we could get clinical labs to agree
that they would just inform the lab of
the of the particular assay use and
until we could get some handle on how to
refine this and and approach the issue
of PTH standardization so in conclusion
and I'll just wind up with a few
comments here we do need to measure PTH
in all stages of chronic kidney disease
because it's important cause of
mortality morbidity and mortality it is
a target for correction and we know if
we can direct treatments and controlling
it we can achieve improvements that only
in the skeleton but in other target
organs for PTH we believe that in this
disease state of chronic kidney disease
we need and the clinicians need to be
aware as well as the laboratory people
of some of their current pitfalls with
PTH assays that the methods are variable
that reference values even are not
defined there are differences between
essays even samples and stability and
storage and shipping etc and so we have
to be vigilant that we try to keep this
as as tight as possible there are other
bone markers that we can use to
complement PTH measurements but they're
not at the stage where they by any means
would replace PTH and there are also new
[ __ ] hormones that are emerging I
mentioned is available fgf 23 there are
other markers like for bone metabolism
that are beginning to come into into
under clinical scrutiny for use here but
are not available in the current panels
of assay
that are used to try and assess these
abnormalities in bone and mineral
metabolism and chronic kidney disease
and a lot more work needs to be done
before these can be incorporated into
routine clinical practice so it is
necessary I think to continue to work
hard and push hard trying to achieve
standardization and PTH assays and to
have some knowledge of the particular
specificities and whether it's other
assets that don't measure these PTH
fragments will actually ultimately be
the way to measure PTH and a lot more
work and data is required before that
might make this whole area a little more
reproducible so with that an overview of
the some of the issues and problems in
kidney disease and the man measurement
of PTH I'm going to stop at this point
in time and I'd be happy to take a try
and address any questions anyone might
have and see if we can clarify any
issues further so thank you very much to
everybody for your attention and as I
said I'd be happy to take any questions
and return this control back to the
studio thank you very much
well thank you very much dr. Martin for
your informative overview and
presentation today before we transition
in today's Q&A I would like to remind
the audience and how to submit questions
you can submit your questions by typing
them in the Q&A box and that is that
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we're going to
try to answer as many questions as we
possibly can during this time so dr.
Martin our first question that we have
do vitamin D supplements have any effect
on C Katie hi can I can address the
first question here by first reading it
to you it's ask how close do you think
you are from refining this test well I
think we're getting closer I think we
have a lot of interest and we've defined
the problem to find the variable
cross-reactivity and measurement of
these fragments it is possible to
eliminate them from the assay we have
worked to develop mass spectrometric
assay and are trying to correlate this
with the two side immunoassays so
hopefully we can get it soon there's an
international group that meets regularly
trying to address the the issue and I
imagine however the next may be
optimistically year or two and we'll be
able to refine this further so I'll turn
you back to her so we could thank you
dr. Martin our next question is how
clear is that PTH fragments come from
the post transitional modifications
right rather than the regularly
events on the RNA such as alternative
splicing for example so the it's
possible all right here most of most of
the fragments arise from intra glandular
and peripheral metabolism but there are
some post translational modifications of
PTH and that also occur and I glossed
over these on the slides I have and
they're they occur in about 1% of the
samples and it's but it's a problem with
only particular assays if the detection
assay is directed at this region where a
post translational modification has
occurred and then it doesn't detect the
PTH and although it is biologically
active you're just not able to measure
it
so these samples do exist and the way to
eliminate them is to don't use an assay
that would have a detection antibody in
this area such as a 1-day 84 PTH assay
but I think we need to learn more about
it and and just be aware that it can be
there and if if one thought there was
severe hyperparathyroidism but the PTH
values you're getting there are not
consistent with that maybe it's
worthwhile to consider using an essay
that just measures PTH 1 to 84 and no
fragments at all it's good question
though thank you so I'll turn you back
to the thank you very much so this next
question that we have is sunlight
enhances skin vitamin D production and
vitamin D is part of the California
regulatory stuff what's the ultimate
effect of sunlight on PTH testing and
chronic disease kidney disease
and as sunlight of course is important
for vitamin D metabolism this is what
makes us convert make where vitamin D
precursors in the skin and contribute to
to our vitamin D in serum so sunlight
contributes and and we get some also
from our diet to have a adequate
production of vitamin D from sunlight
you need to be at least maybe 15 minutes
twice a week arms and legs exposed to
the Sun and and longer than that in the
northern hemisphere so in general it's
it needs some supplementation and
politically in the setting of chronic
kidney disease for vitamin D 25 hydroxy
vitamin D indicating our overall vitamin
D status tends to be low so if there is
some PTH hyperparathyroidism in kidney
disease it's not unreasonable to correct
any existing vitamin D deficiency first
but probably it's best done by Horrell
supplements rather than rely on sunlight
and sunlight just isn't good enough for
most of the people at least in North
America thank you
thank you Wayans there no
standardization of PTH 184 and why are
there no international recommendations
for lambs to you pdh 184 I'm not sure
what then what question was was asked
there but if it's number 60 vitamin D
supplements have any effects on CKD and
the answer is yes and correction of
vitamin D deficiency will suppress
levels of PTH and control
hyperparathyroidism I have to also have
other an effects on the kidney such as
reducing proteinuria so part of the
practice guidelines is to measure
vitamin D status in the presence of
chronic kidney disease and then correct
any any levels as a first step in in
controlling hyperparathyroidism I can
move then to the next question which
asks why is there no standardization for
PTH 1 to 84 and no recommendation for
labs to use to use pta 2084 assays I
think this is evolving and there's a
moves as I said to try to get some
international standardization the World
Health Organization has a standard it's
not necessarily the best standard and
it's not well incorporated into most lab
testing at the moment but there are
regular meetings ongoing and hopefully
with a little more data as to the
appropriate standards and have buy-in
from various manufacturers of PTH assays
I mapped a mistake that we can get there
particularly as these at Pt h1 284 si
has become more available and eliminate
the problem of the of the other 784
family of peptides that really cause a
lot of the variation thank you it's good
question
return it to you Bobby thank you very
much
in one of your slides you mentioned a
multiplication factor of 9y if the
multiplication of a factor of 9 came
from the que digo practice guidelines so
I think what they were trying to do here
is to consider the range of PTH values
that might be encountered using this
spectrum of intact PTH essays that I
mentioned to you and they thought that
there was there was a need to broaden
the range somewhat from the original que
digo recommendations so they base that
on using results from from bone biopsy
correlations which actually used one of
the PTH assays that gives high values
that measures these truncated fragments
very well but they thought that this
would be a reasonable range to recover
most of the assays in use and and really
in the absence of more definitive data
it's hard to argue too strongly with it
because the correlation of PTH values
with parameters of bone histology is
good but not perfect so I think they
they thought that a little mild over
activity was probably okay and rather
than trying to treat to a very narrow
range
risk the idea of over treatment and have
bone turnover excessively low so it's
not an unreasonable range with thee with
the intact asses that are available
today I would add one final word perhaps
is it's best if you know your a say if
he knew the assay you were using his
values on the high side then I would use
the up to the factor of nine if I knew
that the values were on the lower side
in this spectrum of assays that I showed
you my inclination personally speaking
would be to move that down maybe to have
four or five times the upper limit of
normal it's important it's important
really to know your assay and then we
could make reasonable stabs that which
one to use so thank you for the question
I turn it back to you very thank you
with monitoring PTH should be critical
in diagnosing and treating patients with
counseled axis as counseled axis is a
very serious development in patients
with chronic kidney disease or patients
on dialysis there's really a broad
spectrum of patients involved with this
some patients would have severe
hyperparathyroidism
most of these were would have what's
called a peripheral council axis and
certainly monitoring PTH and dealing
with a very high PTH would be critically
important in their management in many
cases of council axis PTH values are
actually low and and perhaps a lower
value of PTH as contributing actually to
the council axis and so in those it can
be helpful in directing your treatment
so if PTH values are very high you would
try and eliminate PTH as a risk
to freak out suplexes even going forward
at parathyroidectomy or treating with
calcium addict agents which can
effectively suppress PTH levels if the
PTH values are low and most of these
will have this central council axis or
you know with necrosis and abdomen or
since our thighs etc and then the
addenda is to try to really use a
multifactorial approach of treating and
there's no point in trying to suppress
PTH further so PTH values are a critical
part of them directing your management
of council axes and certainly are
important to have available for them
thank you for the question
return back to you our thank you dr.
Martin and dr. Martin could you please
elaborate effects of pdh in pregnancy
also in European nation are the European
Union that they have different
measurements of PTH thank you yes
eh can certainly change during the
course of a pregnancy a lot of it
dependent on the on the pre-existing
health and and vitamin D health you know
the PTH levels can increase during
pregnancy and that certainly has been
noted in some patients mostly thought to
the contribution of sending calcium
values to the developing baby with the
placenta can make 125 vitamin D which
can control PTH
so yes PTH is part of the changes in
mineral Attalla metabolism throughout
pregnancy which also involved changes in
vitamin D yeah and in Europe the
situation is a little bit different and
there are many many in-house PTH assays
used throughout Europe and they all have
their own range their own standards
their own types of characterization some
of the commercial assays that are that
are used in Europe are also used in this
country but well the data that I showed
you for heterogeneity a PTH si is even
more of problematic in Europe because of
the of the number of in-house PTH assays
that are used and not available to
everybody so that's a real problem and I
think that's where some of these other
questions that deal with and efforts to
try to achieve international
standardization will be really important
hopefully we can continue to work
forward on that and and and get some
standardization to this issue
I thank you very much dr. Martin and I
do have one final question here does the
increase of pdh fragments in late-stage
affect the sensing membrane to decrease
the amount of in act PTH yes so they the
PTH fragments that accumulate in the
late stages of chronic kidney disease
we don't believe have any significant
biologic activity so I think in and of
themselves I don't think they do any
harm and they just complicate the
measurement really and the risk is that
if you're if you're measuring these
fragments which has a said are inactive
that you can treat over treat
hyperparathyroidism and facilitate the
state a very low bone turnover which has
a lot of problems in and of itself so
it's mainly I think an SI issue and what
we're measuring and it misleads on the
the the the meta levels of PTH that you
are achieving which are put your
therapeutic efforts so it is important
thank you thank you very much so I just
wanted to also just thank you again dr.
Martin for all your informative
information for today I do you have any
final comments
I think thank you I think the final a
comment is to try to spread the word
that PTH assays are heterogeneous and
tried to know which assay is being used
if you can influence it try to have the
labs say which PT PT HSA is being used
and on our end we'll try to continue to
work towards trying to achieve
standardization of PTH so thank you
thank you for all your questions and
attention okay thank you again dr.
Martin I'd also like to thank our
sponsor daya Sauron for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through February 28th you'll
receive an email from Lam roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live events and with
that we'll see you next time goodbye